más
en los primeros vídeos hablamos sobre la
tarea básica de un rey fraser determinar
el color final de cada pixel en una
imagen
veamos un ejemplo real de monsters
university
primero para cada píxel necesitamos
encontrar el punto de intersección de un
rayo que se origina en la cámara
atraviesa un píxel y se dirige hasta la
escena el siguiente paso es preguntar de
qué color es cada una de estas
superficies resulta que el color por sí
mismo no tiene una apariencia muy
interesante verdad luego necesitamos
determinar el modo en que la superficie
responderá a la luz como lo vimos
anteriormente los dos componentes
básicos de la respuesta de una
superficie se conocen como difuminado y
especular esta es una imagen de qué tan
difuminado o mate es cada objeto en los
lugares en los que esta imagen es de un
color blanco brillante ahí es donde la
superficie de la escena es más mate por
ejemplo ese sombrero es realmente mate y
esta es una imagen de que tan especular
brillante es cada objeto ahora partiendo
de esta imagen puedes distinguir en
donde se encuentra la principal fuente
de luz si necesitas un poco más de
tiempo ponle pausa al vídeo ahora la
fuente de luz está hacia el lado
izquierdo de la pantalla de hecho puedes
verla reflejada en el ojo de mike aquí
ahora bien cada objeto de la escena
recibe iluminación directa misma que
vemos aquí en estas imágenes de
difuminado y especular pero también
recibe iluminación indirecta o sea los
que rebota sobre otros objetos de la
escena
entonces qué pasa cuando juntamos todos
estos cálculos
es como algo mágico verdad eso es lo que
hacemos son matemáticas pero usadas para
crear magia